Question with Dr. McCullough's formula for lung infection, how many times a day we think I should debilize.
So this person is talking about this thing. I put the PDF of Dr. McCullough the recipe for his nebulized hydrogen peroxide to help heal the lungs because the last few zoom calls we had questions about issues with lungs, respiratory issues,
flungle infections in the lungs, et cetera, nebulized hydrogen peroxide. And debilizing other things is can be very beneficial. You can debilize below the silver.
You could put a drop of essential oil in with hydrogen peroxide or colloidal silver.
That's again, you're getting whatever you're trying to do. So we get hydro peroxide is a great topical antiseptic.
Why? Because H2O2 is hydrogen peroxide and it can easily give an oxygen free radical.
That can be a danger of consuming hydrogen peroxide orally because oxygen free radicals are free or oxygen radical species that can damage cells and actually be a cause of cancer.
But in a topical setting, it actually kills bacteria because it will attach to bacteria and viruses and fungus and it will kill them.
So that's what makes it a great antiseptic.
So when you're debilizing, it's a great antiseptic for things in your lung.
You have really weak lungs and it has nothing to do with fungus and it has nothing to do with any type of bacterial infection or viral infection or maybe it's asthma or maybe it's an allergy that hydrogen peroxide would not be the thing that I would fabulous.
You debilize hydro peroxide if you think it's some sort of pathogen, some sort of infection, which is very common with cancer. So that's why we talked about that.
But if it's allergies and it's an histamine issue and a mass cell issue, I wouldn't be debilizing hydro peroxide. So there's other choices, but that's not what we're talking about.
How many times a day you can use? You can do this four or five times a day and tell you feel better.
My wife does this a lot because she has made your issues with her lungs from when she was a child and what on medications and her parents were not naturally lighted at all.
And this, I tell you, debilizing hydro peroxide, other things helps hurt them more than anything. So good choices.